[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Shay is
whether the Shay is inona hi Shay Merry
Christmas hi Merry
Christmas good how can we
help hi um so just to cut right to The
Taste I just took out my first student
loan ever um super nerve-wracking it's
for my masters in social work and it's
about 45,000 that's without the interest
so I'm just trying to figure out what's
a great path to start on that like how
to tackle it super fast because I don't
want to be with this debt for like 10
years you just took out your first loan
for a semester or you just finished a
degree program and you have $45,000 in
the
whole no so it's I it's six it's like
6,000 a semester um but they just gave
it all to me at once so it's 40 Grand 45
Grand is what they gave me at once who's
they I've never heard of that
ever it's financial aid FASA FASA so
they just cut you a check and deposit it
for
$445,000 well not into my bank it goes
directly to my school and then they
start paying it that way so it's already
given to my school and my school just
takes it out each okay so you're
starting your Masters and you just
Finance the whole thing well I I here
Dave I bet what's happened is I bet they
have you've been approved for the entire
program I bet that don't have a check
for for I bet your University doesn't
have a check for $45,000 cuz they
wouldn't prepay like that cuz you could
quit you can drop out it could be a
whole thing but my guess is you approved
for the program and the school gave you
a letter that said you've qualified for
$45,000 in federal aid and every
semester you're gonna have to reup and
reup and reup and
reup okay that's my guess as to what
happened I've I've never heard the so
you're you're just starting your
Masters yes you're spend $45,000 to get
a masters in social work to make what
kind of
money not enough it's about 90 grand
which would be Sal or yeah the salary
for it there's no way you'll make 90
grand that's the that is the um salary
in Florida for it where right now I work
at a hospital and this a starting social
worker with the lmsw makes
$90,000
not starting out no but I've been doing
social work and case management and all
that stuff for years so with the
experience and once I get it they're
going I'm already making 50 okay right
now so they're bumping it up wow i'
that's that's extraordinary I'm good for
them because that's that's a that's a
field that needs more people that
drastically is is usually underpaid I
would I as a as a guy who's I've taught
graduate school and mental health
programs I've lived this world what I
would plead to you is is to you make
$50,000 a year I would cut back for the
next three years and cash flow this
program please please please don't chain
yourself to the federal government and
then try to go into a serving
profession it's a recipe for Burnout and
you're gonna it's just going to melt you
from the inside out please don't do
this yeah yeah that was one of my big
fears it's just like I I just definitely
don't want it lingering for so long too
and when it comes to money I just bad
anxiety over it the way the way it
doesn't linger is you don't take it
don't take it don't take the check pay
cash for your degree is what John's
saying $6,000 a semester go pay it
outright for the three semesters plus
your 3,000 hours whatever you Hospital
not got any Financial uh matching for
Education not no because I'm not a nurse
they only have it for nurses
okay and what enticed me to it was
because they said at first that they
would and then when I got here they said
oh sorry no it's just for nurses yeah
I'd find another place to work too while
you're at
it I'm serious 100% serious if they're
gonna if they're going to lure you in
and then they're going to bait and
switch you that's just a that's a
company without Integrity I wouldn't
work for
them gotcha and I know this is a radical
shift but I would go to the school and
say hey I need my semester by semester
cost and they're probably going to tell
you well it depends if you take six or
nine hours whatever and say what is what
is a full-time and what is a part-time
student going to cost and then you make
$50,000 a year until you find another
job where you'll make 60 I want you to
cash flow this so what we're trying to
tell you is that uneasy feeling inside
of you when you called is real it's
right and it's telling you don't do this
and we're telling you it's right don't
do it the best way to get this degree is
pay cash for it and um you know look for
someone maybe another maybe another
employer that pays 90 when you're out
but also uh will help with the education
like this one promised but it was Rigdon
uh and so let's do a couple things here
that are pretty radical but if you kind
of just you you sound pretty chill and
if you kind of just allow all this to
happen to you it's going to step on your
face don't allow this to happen you need
to stand up Square your shoulders and
head straight into this with your teeth
you know with with a warrior yell girl I
mean you need to get after it create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life